[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشرات الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات السعوديه
والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه تقول بانها
ستنشر عشرات السفن المسيره وتطور
تكنولوجيا للتصدي لمسيره ايران
انطلاق وجلسات مؤتمر المنامه والامن
الاقليمي وحركه الملاحه البحريه ضمن ابرز
ملفات النقاش
مقاوي وفوق من تعطر تويتر على خلفيه نقص
الموظفين وماسك يجتمع اليوم عن موظفين
داخل مقر الشركه
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه كذلك
الداخليه السعوديه تعلن ترحيل اكثر من
10,000 مخالف لانظمه الاقامه والعمل خلال
اسبوع
بعد تجربته في مونديال روسيا رحاله سعوديه
يتوجه الى الدوحه بدرجاته الهوائيه
حياكم الله اعلن قائد القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه الجنرال مايكل كورولا في مؤتمر
في البحرين كوريلا في البحرين ان قوه
مخصصه للانظمه غير الماهوله في الخليج
ستنشر اكثر من 100 سفينه مسيره في مياه
المنطقه الاستراتيجيه بحلول العام القادم
واكد المتحدثون نفسه ان اطلاق القوه 59 في
مياه الخليج يهتفوا للتعامل مع التهديدات
ايران من خلال تطوير برنامج تكنولوجي مع
شركاء الولايات المتحده للتصدي لخطر
المسيره الايرانيه مشيرا الى ان نشره هذه
القوه ياتي بهدف الدمج بين السفن المسيره
والذكاء الاصطناعي
وجاءت تصريحاته كوريلا بعدما اتهمت
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده ايران هذا
الاسبوع في الهجوم بطائره بدون طيار على
ناقله نفط تديرها شركه مملوكه لرجل اعمال
اسرائيلي محمله بالوقود قبل التاب عمان
نقلت وكالته فرانسبريس عن مدير في تويتر
قوله ان الرؤيه ضبابيه في الشركه والعاصفه
قادما على حد تعبيري بعد تسريحه اكثر من
نصف موظفي تويتر واستقالتي مئه اخرين
المدير في تويتر
فلوس قال انه لم يبقى سوا ثلاثه مهندسين
من اصل 75 كانوا في فريقه وشارك لوزي لان
ايلون ماسك لم يقدم خطه خماسيه مثل ما فعل
في شركه تسلم معتبرا عندما يفعله ماسك
مجرد اختبار ولاء اكد المدير في تويتر انه
غادر من الصعب لانه لن يضحي من اجل وعود
غامضه على حد قوله
الاستقالات وتسريحه الموظفين من شركه
تويتر يعرض النظام الاساسي لمجموعه واسعه
من الاعطال حيث يتوقع خبراء التكنولوجيا
ان شبكه ستكون عرضه للاختراق والاعطال
وابقى بلومبيرج كما ان هناك مخاوف كثيره
تتجاوز ابقاء المنصه متاحه نظرا لوجود عدد
اقل من الموظفين الامر الذي يفرض على
تويتر مواجهه وقت اكثر صعوبه في التعامل
مع المشكلات التي تواجه الصحه كما اكد
خبراء التكنولوجيا ان تغطيه تفاعليه كاس
العالم ستؤدي الى ثقل اضافي في المنصه
التي تعاني منه حاليا
نشر الملياردير لهم ماسك صور جديده
لاجتماعه مع موظفين في تويتر حول سياسه
المنصه الجديده وجاء ذلك بعد ان اعلن
مزيدا من العاملين في تويتر مغادره من
الصغادات انذار وجهه ماسك طلبه فيه من
الموظفين الناجين من حمله التسريحات
الاولى الاختيار بين العمل بتفان وبلا
شروط او الرحيل
بدا له ماسك اجراء استطلاع على تويتر
يطالب من المستخدمين التصويت على اعاده
تفعيل حساب الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب على المنصه واظهرت نتائج الاستطلاع
الذي شارك فيه حتى الان نحو تسعه ملايين
ان نحو
53% تصوتوا بنعم فيما صوت اكثر من 47%
بلال اذا تغيرات سريعه وجذريه على منصه
العصفور الازرق تويتر بعد سلسله تغريدات
لمالكها له الماسك يوضح فيها سياسه جديده
قائمه على حريه التعبير كما افادت صحيفه
واشنطن بوست الامريكيه بوجود احتماليه عدم
صمود المنصه لوضعه الحرج خصوصا بعد عمليه
التسريح المفاجئه للموظفين واغلاق مكاتبها
بشكل مؤقت
اغلاق مكاتب تويتر بلا سبب سياسات جديده
للمنصه وحكومات وسفارات تستعد للاسوء في
حاله تعطله مؤقتا هذا بعض من المؤشرات
والتغيرات التي قد تحدد مصيره تويتر في
المرحله المقبله الى الماسك الذي استحوذ
على تويتر توجه الى منصته ليوشارك العالم
سياسه جديده قائمه على حريه التعبير وليست
على حريه الوصول على حد قوله ماسك اوضح
ايضا انه سيتم الغاء نشر التغريدات
السلبيه التي تحد على الكراهيه
نهج جديد يتبعه ماسك لتحسين منصه العصفور
الازرق حيث لجا الى المغردين بتغريده تحت
عنوان ما الذي يجب ان يفعله تويتر منهم من
قال تعزيز منع الاحتلال على المنصه واخر
يرغب باضافه خاصيه تحرير التغريدات واعاده
ترتيب التعليقات بطريقه اذكى سياسيا قرر
ماسك اجراء استطلاع على تويتر يطلب من
المستخدمين التصويت على اعاده تفعيل حساب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب على
المنصه وصوت الاغلبيه على رغبتهم بذلك
تداعيات موجه الاستقالات جراء عمليات
التسريح السريع للموظفين من قبل ماسك
تسببت في ظهوره هاشتاج ار اي بي تويتر على
المنصه يوم الخميس والجدير بالذكر انها
ليست الاولى مع تساؤلات لاحتماليه توقف
المنصه عن العمل او ما اذا كان الموظفون
الباقون قادرين على الحفاظ على الشركه هذا
وقد رصدت صحيفه نيو تايمز تغيرات المفاجئه
والسريعه لتعطي قراءها نصائح لحفظ ارشيف
تغريداتهم خصوصا مع وضع المنصه الحرج
واحتماليه عدم صموده وفق الصحيفه واشنطن
بوستنماركيه نقلا عن مصادر داخل تويتر مع
استعداد سياسيين وحكومات وسفارات للاسوء
في حال تعطل تويتر بشكل مؤقت رئيس اداره
الثقه والامن في تويتر سابقا والراث قال
في مقال لصحيفه يور تايمز عندما يحدد
مستقبل تويتر ليس فقط الخيارات التي
تتخذها الشركه ولكن كيفيه القيام بها رشا
خياطه العربيه
[موسيقى]
ومن دبي انضم لنا المحلل الاقتصادي احمد
الخطيب استاذ احمد مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض ربما انت
من
اشد المعجبين
ماسك معرف هذا اليوم انت لسه معجب فيه ولا
لا ولكن السؤال المهم اليوم هل تعتقد بان
مستقبل تويتر اصبح في خطر حقيقي
مساء الخير مساء النور لا لا لا اعتقد
ابدا انه مستقبل تويتر في خطر حقيقي يعني
اذا بدنا ناخذ يعني المعطيات البسيطه انه
قالوا ناس من بدايه السنه او من شهر اربعه
يعني وضع العرض اللي بدو يشتريه هو قبل ما
يضع العرض كان دخل الى مجلس اداره او بده
يدخل مجلس اداره هسه كبيره وبعدين جمع من
المستثمرين وهو 44 مليار دولار ومجرد بدا
الان وعم بيغير التغيرات كبيره فلا اعتقد
يعني انه كل الاشياء عملها همم ولمجلس
يصرح بقى او يخبر الموظفين انه الموضوع
اداره
[موسيقى]
الجده حول الاشياء التي يقوم بها اعتقد
انه عنده كثير من الخطا هلا سينجح او
سيبصل بدنا ننتظر ولكن لا اعتقد انه حاليا
هناك خطر على المنصه التقنيه كيف ستتاثر
هذه المنصه بهذه الخطوات التي اتخذها له
ماسك سواء بتسريح الموظفين او الموظفين
الذين استقاله احد المدراء اليوم في تويتر
يقول بان احد الاقسام المهمه في الشركه
كان فيها 75 مهندسا اليوم اصبحوا ثلاثه
مهندسين فقط ونحن امام بطوله كاس عالم
التفاعل سيكون كبير في موقع تويتر
وبالتالي هناك خطر محدق بهذه المنصه الان
هلا طبعا بناء يعني
موظف او تحليل الاخبار ولكن انا مره اخرى
انا لا اعتقد انه انا انا المصري يعني هو
نوع من الشخص الذي تنقصه الخبره او
المعرفه التقنيه همم يعني يسرح اعداد
كبيره من الموظفين بدون معرفه اثر ذلك على
المنصه هلا انا برايي معظم اللي عم يعمله
حاليا
يعني ال- ال-
التوازن المالي للشركه لانه ما بتتحقق
ارباح ومصاريفها كبيره جدا الجزء الاخر هو
انه بده نوعيه اخرى من التقنيه حتى في
كلام مؤخرا انه همم عم يستعين يعني خارج
دوامهم من بعض المهندسين تسلم
لاعاده النظر في الاشياء اللي موجوده في
تويتر وضع خطه للتحصينه اعتقد انه يعني من
الناحيه التقنيه من ناحيه ال- اا معرفه ما
يجب ان يتم له خوف طيب يعني هو يقول بانه
سيحاول حسين منصه تطوير ال- اا منصه ايضا
والسؤال ياتي في المقلب الاخر كيف ستحسن
هذه المنصه او تطور ادائها او تراقب حتى
الحسابات يسيطر على خطاب الكراهيه
والعنصريه وغيره بدون عدد كافي من
الموظفين
لا يعني اعتقد يعني سيرجع سيعود الى يعني
توظيف موظفين ولكن سيكون عم يعتمد اكثر
على يعني وضع سياسات مختلفه على يعني قد
ماتت بعض الامور ولكن يعني يجب ان ان يبقى
في اعتبارنا دائما ان الموضوع همم شو اللي
بيصير الكراهيه واللي ما بيصير الكراهيه
ويعني لانهم في وجهات نظر هذا الموضوع
دائما دائما
اغلاق المنصه التكرار الاختراقات همم
تكرار الاعطال هناك بعض الصحف والتقنيين
ايضا المختصين في همم هذه المواقع في
تويتر طبعا تحديدا كلهم بانها ستصبح
السماء السائده لتويتر في حال اا طبعا بقي
له ماسك على هذه الاجراءات او اتخذ ايضا
حتى اجراءات مماثله واكثر شده
شوف يعني نحنا اذا بدنا ناخذ تاريخ اول ما
اسمع المنتجات اللي بيتعامل معها تقنين او
اللي بيعمل عليها التقنيه ما عنده تاريخ
بقول انه
بيتعرض لهيك الشاب الشركات اللي هو بديرها
او بيكون مسؤول عنها الجزء الاخر انا براي
المهم جدا انه يعني كونه هو اصلا مش
هالشخص المحبوب جدا من كثير من وسائل
الاعلام كثير اصحاب الراي وهلا بالطريقه
اللي عم يعمل فيها اعتقد عم بكثير يعني عم
يستفزهم بشكل اكبر وخصوصا لما بنحكي عن
موظفين عم بتتم مثلا تسريحتهم او اثارهم
من تويتر بيطلعوا بيحكوا بعض القصص او بعض
الاراء همم الاعلام بيركز عليها بشكل معين
همم اعتقد هناك مبالغات كبيره في هذا
الموضوع حاليا لانه يعني بقول انه الصفقه
44 مليار دولار مش دفعها لواحده يعني مش
عم يتسلى هو في مستمرين كبار جدا دخله معه
اكيد بعد ان قدها عرض لخطته بتغيير وضع
المنصه و- يعني مستقبلنا
عن نقطه مهمه يعني مثلا باحد الموظفين
الذين غادروا المدير ايضا في تويتر يقول
بان ماسك لم يقدم مثلا خطه خمسيه لتويتر
مثل ما فعل مع تسلا ما يفعله اليوم وهو
مجرد اختبار ولا للموظفين هل يمكن ان تكون
همم هذه سياسه لرجل يدير او يملك منصه
مهمه مثل المنصه همم تويتر بانه يسعى
لتحسينها وتطويرها كما يقول
همم
يعني بدات تظهر ملامحها ولكن يعني كمان ما
ننسى انه ما عنده تاريخ جيد في يعني سمعته
في التعامل مع الناس ولا مع الموظفين
اسلوب اسلوب التعامل الخاص يعني والاسلوب
يعني اللي كثير بيقول عنه انه بيحاول يقلد
ستيف جوبز الموضوع يعني معروف عنه في تسله
وكل مكان تواجد فيه يعني ليس الشخصيه
المحبوبه المنفتح للنقاش او اللي يعني
الديمقراطي خلينا نقول اطلاقا متوقع جدا
انه ال- ال- ال- الاشياء اللي عملها حاليا
تثير يعني تستفز الموظفين او بيحكوا عنه
ولكن انا اذا بتقول لي في موظف عم يحكي
انه مستقبل تويتر سيء وقال له ماسك عم
بقول انا عندي خطر انا هلا بمشي اكثر
الموتورات تويتر السابقين
اشكرك
على الاقتصادي احمد الخطيب شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا
[موسيقى]
قال الامين العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
نايف الحجره فينا الاتفاق النووي مع ايران
في عام 2015 لا يراعي الامن بالمنطقه
واضاف للحجره خلال كلمه له في مؤتمر
الحوار بالمنامه ان اي اتفاق غربي مع
ايران يجب ان يراعي سلوك طيران المزعزع
للاستقرار
مجلس التعاون ان دعم ايران لدول اخرى
بالمسيرات جعل الغرب يفهمه
منه هذا وكان المنتدى 18 للامن الاقليم
حوار المنامه 2002 قدم
رفيعه المستوى من مختلف دول العالم يهدي
في المنتدى مشاهدينا الى تبادل الخبرات
ومن مناقشه القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه
ذات الاهتمام المشترك فيما تسهم جلساته في
تعزيز مناقشه القضاء الى استراتيجيه التي
تشكل تحديات تتطلب وتنسيقا دوليا للتعام
معها وايجابي حلول سريعه لها ودعم المساعد
دوليه لتعزيز الامن وترسيق السلام ومكافحه
هذه هو التطرف بشتاب صوره واشكاله
من الملامه ينضم الينا موفد العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
قضايا استراتيجيه كثيره نقشت في هذا
المنتدى ابرز ما تم نقاشه حتى اليوم طرح
من ملفات ومواضيع تخص المنطقه
جلسات مستمره نحن الان وصلنا الى الجلسه
الرابعه والاخيره كما نشاهد على الشاشه
الان وزير الخارجيه العراقي يتحدث في هذه
الجلسه الرابعه نايف التي تتمحور حول همم
مبادرات الشرق الاوسط لحل النزاعات
الاقليميه يتحدث ايضا معه امين العام
لمجلس التعاون الخليجي نايف الحجره ووزيره
خارجيه مملكه ايضا اليوم شهدت جلسات مهمه
جدا حول اساليب الدفاع والتكنولوجيات
الجديده بالاضافه الى تاثير النزاعات خارج
المنطقه على امن الشرق الاوسط وبالاضافه
الى المتغيرات الجيوس السياسيه للطاقه
اسماء مهمه
في هذا المؤتمر وزير خارجيه الكويت وزير
خارجيه همم اليمن كان موجود ايضا وزير
خارجيه العراق نائب وزير الخارجيه السعودي
وليد الخريجي بالاضافه الى طبعا وزير
خارجيه بريطانيا ووزير اجيت في لندن
والاسماء عديده جدا ايضا نائب وزير الدفاع
المصري وعدد كبير اكثر من 400 عسكري
ومسؤول اتحدث وحضروا هذه همم
القمه قمه الامن همم في البحرين تحت عنوان
حوار المنامه في نسختها الثامنه عشر نايف
تاتي اهميه هذا الحوار بانه هناك عده
لقاءات جانبيه ايضا تقام على هامش همم هذه
القمه وزير الداخليه البحرين التقى ايضا
بعدد من المسؤولين وايضا نائب وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه التقى بنغرائه من الدول
الاوروبيه الحديث والجلسات ركزت بشكل كبير
على التحديات التي تواجهها المنطقه
الاساسيه في ملف علم مناخ والطاقه ايضا
ايضا التهديدات الايرانيه حضرت همم يعني
بقوه في الجلسات كان هناك عدد كبير من
الاسئله من الصحفيين والخبراء للمتحدثين
الوزراء في حول مستقبل اا ملف النووي
الايراني وايضا الاحتجاجات والمظاهرات في
ايران وانعكاساتها على المنطقه وعلى ايضا
الداخل الايراني ايضا ملف المناخ نايف كان
حاضر بقوه خاصه بعد قمه كوب 227 في شرم
الشيخ المتعلقه بالمناخ
والتوصيات وايضا نتائج هذه القيمه
ومخرجاتها ومدها فعليه تحقيقها على ارض
الواقع نايف ايضا من المتوقع ان همم يوم
غد سيكون الختام طبعا لحوار المنامه هناك
جلستين صباحيتين سيكون اغلب المتحدثين
فيها هم من الرجال همم العسكريين
والامنيين ستتحدثون عن موضوع التسليح في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وتكنولوجيا التسليح
هناك ايضا من المتوقع ان يكون نائب وزير
الدفاع الامريكي حاضر في احد الجلسات يوم
غد صباحا همم ايضا هذه الجلسات بعدها يتم
اختتام صور المنامه في نسخته الثامن عشر
ومن المتوقع نايف ان يخرج هذا الحوار بعده
توصيات كما هو معتاد في كل عام ابرز
التوصيات ستؤكد على اهميه الحفاظ على
الامن الاقليمي في الشرق الاوسط والخليج
العربي ايضا فيما يتعلق بملف الطاقه
وتعزيزها
والدعم لها وتحقيق الامن في ما يتعلق طاقه
في الشرق الاوسط ايضا همم فيما يتعلق
بالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه نايف ايضا
اليوم تحدث عدد من الوزاره الاساسيه
الالماني تكلم عن هذا الملف باسهاب خلال
الجلسه الثانيه همم منذ صباح اليوم اشكرك
جزيل شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
بالمنامه وفد العربيه عبد الرحمن
نعود مره اخرى الى الملف الاول الذي بدانا
به هذه النشره في ما يتعلق بنشر قوه وسفن
مسيره في مياه الخليج العربي ينضموا الينا
من القاهره الباحث في وحده الدراسات
الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام
للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه احمد
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض
يعني هذا الاعلان من قبل القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه عن نشر مئه سفينه عن تطوير
تكنولوجيا ايضا جديده لمواجهه المسيرات
الايرانيه هل اصبحت مواجهه القرصنه مسيرات
الايرانيه حاجه ملحه الان ام يمكن فهم هذه
الخطوه بانها رد فعل مثلا على الهجوم الذي
استهدف ناقله مملوكه لرجل اسرائيلي قبل
اسبوع من الان
يعني الامر يحتمل الفرضتين في الحقيقه
لانه احنا قدام
تهديدات مستدامه من الجانب الايراني رجعنا
او عودنا الى موجه جديده من الارهاب
الملاحي في هذه المنطقه لكن بالنسبه لما
يتعلق
بالمسار ايضا تطوير شكل ونمط وطبيعه
الانتشار العسكري الامريكي
والتعاون ما بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وحلفاء في المنطقه ياخذ مسار
جديد القوات 59 على سبيل المثال التي يعني
اعلن عنها السنتكم او القاده المركزيه هي
تاكيد على المؤكد الذي سبق الاعلان عنه في
ديسمبر العام الماضي وبالتالي هذا الاعلان
هو ياتي بالتزامن مع ما يحدث من الموجه
الجديده من حرب الناقلات والارهابي
الملاحي الايراني في المنطقه واعاده ايضا
دفع الوكلاء في المنطقه للزيامه المليشه
الحوسيه في اليمن الى
الانخراط الموازي في هذا الدور عبر
الارهاب الذي تمارسه ومشاهدناه في موانئ
حضرموت والشبه في الفتره الماضيه وايضا
اعلانها بالامس عن انها تجري تجربه على
الصاروخ في عام 208 الصيني ليه يشكل ايضا
او احداث التهديد البحري
هذا
المنطقه وهذه الرؤيه سيد احمد ولكن هناك
من يذهب بالقول او السؤال همم انه هل
تاخرت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في خطوه
كهده هذه المرحله التي نمر فيها ليست اولد
المراحل التي كانت تشكل فيها ايران تهديدا
علميا الخليج العربي وعلى ناقلات
نعم انا اتفق مع حضرتك تمام دلوقتي مفتاح
الامريكيه تاخرت كثيرا في هذا السياق لم
يكن هناك ادراك لي خطر مستوى التهديد
الايراني هذا شاهدناه كثيرا في التعرض او
في الهجمات التي شنتها على منشات نفط في
الخليج كان بمقدار الامريكيه انتم يمارس
سياسه الرعد لكنها استمرت طويلا تحاول ان
توازن ما بين هذه السياسه وما بين محاولات
الدبلوماسيه همم التي قادت الى مسار فاشن
للعوده للاستئناف المفاوضات النوويه لكن
في الاخيره الان همم ايران ترى ان هذا
المسار هي الاخرى ترى ان هذا المسار همم
لن يكتب له النجاح وبالتالي هتعزز او تعود
مره اخرى ادراجها الى سياستها او قواعد
اللعبه القديمه وبالتالي هذا ايضا احد
الدروس المستفاده انه الولايات المتحده
حتى لو كان هناك مصارا دبلوماسيه كان لا
يجب ان تتوقف عن المسار الخاص بتطوير
القدرات الموجوده فيها هذه المنطقه بعد
الكوارث التي تسببت فيها ايران وتطويرها
لقدرتها ولكنها الان تستوعب هذا الدرس بعد
ان اصبح هذا المعطى لا يختصر فقط على
المنطقه العربيه والشرق الاوسط ولكن اصبح
جزء من التهديد في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه همم من المنظور الامريكي
المساله الاخرى انه حتى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كان لديها نوع من التقاعد
احيانا او المساومه مع الدول في ما يتعلق
بالمساله الامن حينما سحبت بعض المنظومات
الدفاعيه مثل باتريوت من بعض المناطق في
العراق وفي المملكه العربيه السعوديه انا
اعتقد ان هذا المؤشر كان خطيره في السابق
الان هناك استدراك
لهذه المواقف من الجانب الامريكي اشكرك
جزيلا شكرا من القاهره الباحث في وحده
الدراسات الامنيه العسكريه في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
احمد علاء شكرا لك
الرابعه مستمره تتابعون فيها بعد قليل
انطلاق اولى رحلات جماهير المنتخب السعودي
من مطار الرياض الى الدوحه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد خلال اسبوع في
السعوديه اكثر من 16 الف مخالف لانظمه
الاقامه والعمل وامن الحدود ضبطتهم وزاره
الداخليه خلال حملتها الامنيه المشتركه
حيث شكل عدد مخالفين نظام الاقامه النسبه
الاكبر بنحو 10 الاف مخالف الداخليه
السعوديه كشفت ايضا عن القبض على اكثر من
اربعه الاف في مخالف لنظام امن الحدود
بينما بلغ عدد مخالفين نظام العمل ما
يتجاوز ال 2000 مخالف خلال اسبوع
في السعوديه يواصلوا مشروع تطوير الواجهات
البحريه بابحر في مدينه جده اعماله التي
شاركت على الانتهاء حيث يجري تنفيذ
المشروع على امتداد كيلو مترين ونصف مساحه
180 الف متر مربع بقيمه الاجماليه تجاوزت
المئتين 229 مليون ريال يضم مشروع تطوير
واجهه ابحر منشن بحريا ومسار للدراجات
بالاضافه الى المباني الاستثماريه
والشواطئ الرمليه على امتداد كامل المشروع
منها ما هو مخصص للسباحه واخرى وخصصت
للجلوس
من المشروع ينضموا الينا مراسل العربيه
هاني سبيا هاني مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه ااا من الرياض والابتسامه
ما شاء الله يا هاني
دائما وابدا كل كيف شفت ال ال
المشروع يا هاني الى اين وصل هل شرف فعلا
على الانتهاء
هو الابتسامه كان قبلها ضحكات المنطقه هذه
وانت تتذكرها جيد في 2016 كنت متواجد فيها
طبعا ما اعرف كنت بتغرق اثناء السباحه ولا
لا لكن كان جزء من هذه المنطقه كانت
المنطقه ااه شاطئ رملي طبعا الان هذه
المنطقه تحولت تماما واصبحت واجهه بحريه
الان تستعد لها جده بان تكون من افضل
الواجهات البحريه همم وتنافس والجهات
البحريه على مستوى العالم طبعا اليوم
نتكلم عن واجهه ابحر ويا ابحر الجنوبيه
طبعا هناك ايضا مشاريع لامانه منطقه جده
في همم او امانه مدينه جده في الواجهه
الاخرى وواجهه ابحر الشماليه ولكن اليوم
نتكلم عن هذه المنطقه طبعا كانت تقريبا
اشبه بمنطقه واجهه عشوائيه لان كان تقريبا
هي واجهه جزء منها كورنيش وجزء منها شاطئ
رملي ولكن كان غير مهتمه فيها من الخدمات
كانت غير مهتمه ايضا غير لا يتوفر فيها
سبل الراحه بالنسبه للزائرين وايضا السياح
طبعا هذا الكلام كان تقريبا قبل 2016
اليوم هي تغيرت كامل هي اليوم اصبحت تعمل
ضمن استراتيجيه رؤيه السعوديه اننا نتحدث
عن بنا تحتيه ولا نتحدث عن اشكال جماليه
ولكن نتحدث ان هذه المنطقه ايضا هي تعمل
بالطاقه النظيفه من خلال الخدمات المتوفره
فيها تعمل ايضا بالطاقه الشمسيه من خلال
دفع مصاري همم الصرف الصحي الى شبكات
الصرف الصحي المخصصه في مدينه جده نشاهد
ايضا البنيه التحتيه التغيرت واختلفت اما
كانت المشاريع التي كانت قبل عقود في
السعوديه وكانت ظهرت بشكل غير جيد وفي
البنيه التحتيه اليوم نشاهدها بشكل اختلاف
كلي كلي طبعا 50% من هذه المواجهه هي سوف
تكون ايضا ضمن استراتيجيه السعوديه في
مشروعها انت تصبح وديها سعوديه همم
بمسطحات خضراء واشجار ايضا 50% من هذا
المشروع سوف يصبح كم مسطحات خضراء بالنسبه
لي هذه المناطق الان طبعا هذه المشاريع
لم تستكمل حتى الان ولكن هي في طور عمليه
الاستكمال طبعا
يميز هذا الامر غير انه مشروع وغيره انه
بنيه تحتيه وخدمات توفرها امانه مدينه جده
هذا المطل الجميل المعروف في ابحر الشمالي
او او الجنوبيه وخاصه انا بعد عمليه
التنظيف المستمر الذي تقوم به امانه مدينه
جده واصبح متنفس جميل بالنسبه ليس فقط
لزوار مدينه جده او ايضا السكان في مدينه
جده بل اصبحوا السياح لن ننسى ان الشهر
الماضي حضر في مدينه جده اكثر من 30,000
سائح وصلوا قبل ان يتجهون الى همم ايضا
حضورهم وهم وصلوا مرحله ترانزيت قبل
توجهها الى حضور نهائيات كاس العالم
المقامه في قطر هذه هي الواجهه وهذه هي
ابحر الجنوبيه
زياده ممكن توصل ابحر الشماليه
نقول لك شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه المعلومات
والتوصيل اللي وافق
تسبح اليوم بيتنا فيها مشروع تطوير واجهه
البحريه بابحر في محافظه جده مراسل
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
انطلقت اليوم اول الرحلات الجويه التي تقل
مشجعيه المنتخب السعودي من مطار الملك
خالد الدولي بالرياض الى كاس العالم في
قطر بلغت اعداد الموسىرين على الرحله
الاولى اكثر من 130 ومسافرا حيث خصص
المطار صالتين متكاملتين لخدمات المسافرين
الى الدوحه وذلك لتسهيل اجراءاتهم وتحقيق
الانسيابيه في حركه المسافرين
همم يشترط للمسافرين الراغبين اللي حضور
مباريات كاس العالم في قطر الشقيقه
الحصول على بطاقه هيئه وذلك باستخدام جواز
السفر وتسجيله في منصه هيا ليتمكن من
السفر عبر ملصقات الجوازات اضافه
نحدن نؤكد على موضوع احضار جواز السفر
لكون الهويه الوطنيه لا تقبل كوثيقه سفر
للسفر الى دوله قطر الشقيقه في هذه الفتره
الحاليه
طلق الرحاله السعوديه فهد اليحيى في رحله
على دراجته الهوائيه لدعم المنتخب بلاده
في رحله بدات من الرياض وتنتهي في السفاره
السعوديه في الدوحه ومن المتوقع ان تستغرق
رحلته تسعه ايام يقطع خلالها 800 كم
بمعدل يومي يصل 120 كيلو متر تقريبا يذكر
انه سبق للرحاله السعوديه القيام برحله
سابقا انطلقت من العاصمه الرياض الى موسكو
خلال مونديال كاس العالم في روسيا 2018 في
رحله استغرقت بضاعه اشهر
ومن منفذ سلوى الحدوديه ينضم الينا
الرحاله فهد اليحيى كابتن فهد مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
على القوه اولا
وقال لي اولا ااا كم قطعه حتى هذه اللحظه
في هذه الرحله كما استغرقت حتى الان
الحدود ده بين السعوديه وقطر في منفذ سلوى
همم قطعنا تقريبا لنا تسعه ايام وانطلقنا
من الرياض من مكتب وزير الرياضه مع الامير
عبد
الامير همم
حلال احنا في الحدود مده الرحله تسعه ايام
قطعنا تقريبا يوميا 100 الى 120 كيلو
ممتازه وتقطعها فيه كم ساعه يوميا
يوميا من ثلاثه الى اربع ساعات 100 كيلو
من ثلاثه الى اربع ساعات طيب طيب ممتاز
انت همم طبعا المبيت وهمم ايضا همم الفريق
المساعد ايضا همم كمان معك همم كابتن فهد
همم كيف تتعاملته مع الرحله حتى هذه
اللحظه واجهته صعوبات وغير ايضا
كان معي ابطال هم سر نجاح هذه الرحله
ال- الاعلام المميز عبد الرحمن المطيري
والمهندس ابراهيم الرومي والاستاذ سلطان
السبيعي هذول هم ابطال الرحله وهم من
حققوا هذا النجاح المبهر
طيب انت كل يوم تاخذ تقطع ثلاثه الى اربع
ساعات 100 كيلو و تقريبا كنت تقدر تقطع ها
المسافه في ساعه او ساعه ونصف من الرياض
الى الدوحه بالطائره ليش اخترت انك تروح
الى قطر على الدراجه الهوائيه
عن هذا الحلم
عنده سنوات
ذكرت تقريبا 2018 في روسيا انا دائما احب
اني اذن المنتخب بلادي الاخضر همم بطريقه
خاصه على درجه الهوائيه وان يعني نوصل
الرساله للعيبه الصقور والخبر ان الجماهير
السعوديه خلف كل كل
السيارات
والمراكز المتقدمه للمنتخب السعودي ايش
الاختلاف بين الرحله اللي انت كنت فيها
الى روسيا غير طبعا التوقيت ايش الاختلاف
اللي لما استمر رحلتك الروسيه في مونديال
2018 واليوم في انك تذهب الى الدوحه لحضور
مونديال 2002 22
الفرق ان 2018 كانت المسافه طويله 5145
كيلو دفعتها في 75 يوم ولكن ما اخذ
التغطيه عليه 100 كبيره
الرحله هذه اقصر منها بكثير تقريبا 800
كيلو اخذ التغطيه اعلاميه كبيره جدا جدا
يعني تعدت الوطن العربي
الرحلات سواء وانت رايح القطار او لما
ذهبت ايضا لروسيا موقف عالق في الدهن ما
يغيب
كنت في روسيا في منطقه اسمها كراسنا دار
قبل موسكم 500 كيلو وكنت يعني قريب من
تحقيق الحلم والوصول فااا كنت قاعد اناظر
الجوال على الخريطه
ورفعت راسي الى السيارات موقفه اني قدامي
ولا قدامي تريله دخلت التريله جاني ضربه
في الراس وفي الاسنان وتكسر السيكل
وقعدت يوم كامل كنت خايف اني ما استطيع
اني اواصل الرحله لكن الحمد لله
طبعا هذه ما منعتك انك تكرر الرحله مره
ثانيه وتكرر هذه الخطوه
ابدا وو القادم افضل وانا الان صدر
لموافقه من وزاره الرياضه والداخليه
والخارجيه اني اعمل اطول وحده في العالم
لفه على الكره الارضيه خمس قارات 84 دوله
70 الكيلو الى خلال سنتين وشيرين راح
نقضيها العام القادم انت تستخدم
الدراجه خلال الرحله كامله يعني ما تعتمد
على اي وسيله نقل الاخرى ابدا لا لا على
الدراجه ابدا كل
شيء عند الاستراحه هذا البرنامج عالمي
يخلي كل الدراجين في العالم يراقبوا له
يتابعونك ويحفظ لك السيتي بعدين لما تشوف
وين رحتكم في المسافه كل شيء صرافه هذه
انت مو متوقع توصل الدوحه اليوم وغدا
اليوم بالليل ان شاء الله معزومين عند
اخواننا القطريين الله يعطيه العافيه ابن
سالمين قدم لنا كل الدعم الاعلامي
واستقباله الترحيب وبكره ان شاء الله
الصباح نكون في السفاره خادم الحرمين
الشريفين اللي نسلم التميمه ساعه السفير
اللي تم التوقيع عليها وانها الرحله بشكل
رسمي باذن الله الحمد لله على السلامه
مقدما شكرا جزيلا همم لكم المنفى سلوى
الحدودي ينضم الينا الرحال السعودي
رابع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
الارصاد العمانيه تحذر من تاثر بعض مناطق
البلاد منخفض جوي يوميا الاثنين والثلاثاء
القادمين
حياكم الله من جديد نتابع واياكم هذه
الصور لاستقبال الرئيس الاوكراني
لاستقبال الرئيس الاوكراني
لرئيس الوزراء
البريطانيك اليوم في همم العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف اذا هذه الصور نتبعها الان
لاستقبال الرئيس الامريكي رئيس وزراء
بريطانيا
اجتمع به كما نشاهد مع عدد من القيادات
ربما العسكريه الاوكرانيه مع رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني الجديد همم
زياره الاولى التي يقوم همم بها اذا الى
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف همم ربما كانت
الزياره الاخيره لمسؤول بريطاني كبير على
نفس سواء كانتر رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
السابق كانت في هذا العام ايضا الان نتابع
هذه الصور هذه
الاوربما
المحادثات التي تمخض عنها نتائج مهمه تحدث
عنها طبعا بهذا الشكل رئيس همم الرئيس
الاوكراني فلوديمير زينسكي وقال بانه
مناقشه عدد من الملفات وهناك نتائج مهمه
رشوا حتى عن هذه همم
مقابله او هذا الاجتماع بين الرئيس
الاوكراني في الودميسك رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني الجديد معين ريشي سونيك بعوده
الى هذه النشره انطلق في السعوديه مؤتمر
ومستقبل الازياء بشراكته استراتيجيه مع
عدد من الشركات ومجموعه واسعه من الخبراء
في صناعه الازياء العالميه المؤتمر انطلق
تحت تنظيمه هيئه الازياء شركه في 30 موسم
همم مشاركه فيه 30 مصممه سعوديه من برنامج
100 براند سعودي 100 براند سعودي كما
تضمنا معلومات واحصاءات حول قطاع الازياء
السعودي ومراحل ازدهاره
ومن ملتقى الازياء في الرياض ينضم الينا
الانيق مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز مساء
الخير يا نواف مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض ما الذي رصدته حتى هذه
اللحظه في هذا الملتقى ملتقى الازياء
الحديث عن اكثر من 30 مصممه من السعوديه
شركات ايضا همم سعوديه وعالميه مشاركه في
هذا الملتقى
اهلا بك نايف وشكرا لك في ثالث ايام مؤتمر
مستقبل الازياء تختتم اليوم فعاليات هذا
المؤتمر وهذا الحدث الذي نظمته هيئه
الازياء السعوديه وجمع المصممين العالميين
والاقليين والمحليين في مكان واحد هنا في
مركز مدينه الامير محمد بن سلمان غير
الربحيه اجتمعوا على مدار ثلاثه ايام من
خلال جلسات حواريه اضافه الى ورش عمل
لتبادل الخبرات ونقل المعرفه في مجال
تصميم الازياء
الحدث حقيقه جمع العديد من همم المصممين
العالميين منهم السعودي محمد اشي الذي جاء
من فرنسا للحضور افتتاح هذا المؤتمر وتحدث
لاول مره على المسرح عن التجربه التي مر
بها عند بدايته في تصميم الازياء تفاصيل
اكثر عن هذا المؤتمر مع الان همم العمر
السقاف عضو مجلس اداره جمعيه الازياء
السعوديه اهلا وسهلا بك سيد عمر في
البدايه همم كيف يدعم هذا المؤتمر تصميم
الازياء وقطاع الازياء في السعوديه السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته هذا المؤتمر هي
مبادره من وزاره الثقافه من نهايه الازياء
لعمل حدث اعتقد هو حدث عالمي لم يسبقنا
احد فيه في انه يسموا ملتقى باسم مستقبل
الازياء وسيستمر مستقبل الازياء ان شاء
الله ينطلق من الرياض والفكره هي احداث
نقله نوعيه في مجال صناعه وتصميم الازياء
وتنميه هذا القطاع العام الذي اعتمر من
القطاعات الهامه في اي دوله همم
الهيئه همم عملت على ان هي تجمع في هذا
الملتقى همم كل همم اطراف ذات العلاقه في
مجال تصميم وصناعه الازياء من الشباب من
الناس اللي بالفعل احنا عندنا همم
همم الابداع والابتكار الموجود ويحتاج الى
تمكين من خلال ورش عمل من خلال همم بعد
همم يعني جابوا بعض المعاهد اللي جاءت من
ايطاليا مع هدين مهمين جدا في هذا المجال
اعطاهم فكره كيف التصميم الافتراضي
واعطيهم كيف التصاميم للمنفعاليات ولل
الاشياء اللي احنا اساسا نحتاجها الان مع
النقله مع البرامج اللي شغاله فيها همم
سيد عمر نحن الان يعني نتواجد في معرض همم
30 همم مصمم سعودي يعرضون يعرضون المنتجات
والازياء الخاصه بهم كيف هذا المعرض يدعم
الشباب السعودي الناشئين في هذا المجال
طبعا المجموعه هذه المجموعه مش المجموعه
الكامله اللي راحت ميلان وراحت نيويورك هي
مجموعه همم جبناها نماذج هنا انحطت الهيئه
لعرض همم لعرض همم
مخرجاتهم وهمم
واعمالهم اللي تمثل وتحبر عن ثقافه وعن
قطاع مهم جدا عندنا فلو شفنا مثلا من ال-
من ال- من الدرعيه شوفي في في تصميم
استوحى من الدرعيه شيء يعني يعني يعني
ناتي هنا في يعني كل ان عن كل الشكر لك
سيد عمر السقاف كما نشاهد نايف هنا همم
نود الاشاره الى تصميم همم من مصمم سعودي
يعبر عن همم
يعبر عن الدرعيه وهذا همم هذه الازياء
مستوحه من الدرعيه نضيف طيب ان همم
سيتم تحويله مستقبلا خلال الاشهر القادمه
لدعم همم
وظيفه الكريم والملتقى الازياء في الرياض
شكرا لك
وقعت الارصاد العمانيه تاثر اجواء السلطنه
بمنخفض جوي يومي الاثنين والثلاثاء واشارت
الى تاثر محافظات مسندم وشمال الباطن
وجنوب الباطنه بهطول الامطار رعديه
متفاوته الغزاله مصحوبه برياح هابطه نشطه
احيانا مع فرصه لتشكل السحب الركامي على
جبال الحجر وطول الامطار الرعديه على
انحاء متفرقه من البلاد
تعيش محافظه رفحاء في منطقه الحدود
الشماليه السعوديه اجواء ممطره متواصله من
عده ايام
البر والمتنزهين لشد الرحال الى الصحراء
للاستمتاع برؤيه الفياض وهي ممتلئه بالمئه
زميل جزاء عن المعاصره صدق هذه الاجواء
فانا بهذا التقرير
[موسيقى]
اجواء ساحره تعيشها هذه الايام محافظه
رفحاء بمنطقه الحدود الشماليه السعوديه
بردو مطر واحيانا زخاتم من البرد اجواء
مشجعات البر لشد الرحال الى الصحراء يلا
يا رب لك الحمد اليوم قبل عشر دقائق
وادوار بعد هرمون السعاده فوق فوق من كبار
وصغار
[موسيقى]
الفياض الممتلئه بالمياه جذبت المتنزهين
للاستمتاع بمناظرها الطبيعيه الخلابه هنا
فيضه الحيره احدى هذه الفياض التي باتت
وجهه سياحيه بريه
هذه
وتعتبر
منتجه على اهالي رفحه متنفس لهم موقعه
جنوب رابحه بحدود 15 كيلو ولكن هناك وصله
من المفرق
بحدود اربعه كيلو واعره نطلب من المسؤولين
تمهيد الطريق
للمكان بسهوله
[موسيقى]
رفيضه الحياه بتربتها الحمراء وباشجار
السدر الذي عاده ما يكون مثمره في مثل هذه
الاوقات ويعرف ثمر بعده مسميات كالنبق
والبسر من فيضه الحرجه جنوب محافظه رفحاء
جزاع النماصي العربيه
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه تقول بانها
ستنشر عشرات السفن المسيره وتطور
تكنولوجيا لتصدي لمسيره ايران
انطلاق جلسات مؤتمر المنامه ولمن
الاقليميه وحركه من راحه البحريه ضمن ابرز
ملفات النقاش
مخاوف من تعطل تويتر على خلفيه نقص
الموظفين وماسك يجتمعوا اليوم مع الموظفين
داخل مقر شركه
الداخليه اكثر من 10,000 مخالف لي انظمه
الاقامه العمل خلال اسبوع
[موسيقى]